l'ambiguïté entretenue par votre
gouvernement sur le sujet la laïcité
particulièrement inquiétante alors que
les communautarismes menace des
quartiers entiers alors que l'islam
politique et son idéologie mortifère
n'ont jamais été aussi influent nous ne
pouvons pas nous ne devons pas transiger
avec la laïcité la liberté religieuse et
bien sûr fondamental mais elle doit
s'exercer dans le stricte vu le strict
respect des lois de la république
or votre discours et surtout votre
action laisse perplexe aurait cogné pour
ce qui concerne la laïcité à l'école
j'en veux pour preuve le scandale des
affiches de la fédération des conseils
de parents d'élèves
ces affiches publicitaires qui flatte
ostensiblement le communautarisme en
encourageant le port du voile des
accompagnateurs de sorties scolaires
affiches qui ont profondément choqué
l'opinion ministres disent contraints de
l'éducation a d'ailleurs connaît les a
d'ailleurs condamné mais votre majorité
reste tétanisée sur un sujet de fond des
signes religieux ostentatoires dans la
sphère publique
je rappelle d'ailleurs que l'amendement
ciotti a déjà posé ce problème
l'examen de la loi sur l'école de la
confiance il y a quinze ans
le président chaque chef jacques chirac
et le courage d'interdire le port du
voile à l'école
mais comment accepter que ce qui est
interdit à l'école puissent être
autorisés dans les sorties scolaires qui
relève justement du temps scolaire à
partir de mon expérience celle d'une
élue qui a vu progresser dans nos
quartiers
le communautarisme qui a vu les jeunes
femmes se mettre le voile porté le voile
sous la pression alors que leur mère
sans été libérés le voile en 2019 n'est
pas anodin et nous aurions tort de le
considérer comme une expression d'une
pratique religieuse d'ailleurs beaucoup
de femmes musulmanes dans notre pays ne
le porte pas le voile est trop souvent
le symbole d'un islam politique qui
considèrent plus la femme comme un objet
soumis que comme un individu un individu
émancipé pour reprendre un qualificatif
cher au président de la république nous
aurions tort de baisser les yeux et ne
pas voir que le port de signes religieux
ostentatoires dans le cadre des sorties
scolaires est un instrument de
prosélytisme et parfois même de
provocation nos agriculteurs se
désespère leurs revenus sont en moyenne
de 500
euros par mois les plus jeunes sont
endettés et les plus âgés désespéré par
le montant de leurs faibles pensions en
france la grille bashing atteint son
paroxysme alors que les productions
françaises sont parmi celles qui offrent
les meilleures garanties en termes de
qualité et de traçabilité
soyons en fiers la loi et galim qui
devait être l'alpha et l'oméga des
relations entre producteurs et grande
distribution de se révèle comme une
déception de plus que vous nous vous
avions d'ailleurs prédit lors des débats
dans cet hémicycle sans être écoutés
lors de la présentation de ce texte le
gouvernement a affiché sa volonté de
rééquilibrer les relations commerciales
entre les agriculteurs et les enseignes
de la grande distribution en vue
d'améliorer la rémunération des
producteurs
l'objectif est loin d'être atteint non
seulement la loi et galim n'améliore en
rien la situation des agriculteurs mais
les consommateurs subissent une hausse
des prix en magasin en effet la hausse
de 10 % du seuil de revente à perte va
faire perdre aux consommateurs français
1,6 milliard d'euros de pouvoir d'achat
sur deux ans votre présentation
politique du budget de la france pour
2020 est un trompe l'oeil
un exercice de communication sans
perspective d'avenir contrairement à ce
que vous affirmez
comment pouvez vous parler d'avenir
alors que nous vivons à crédit que les
baisses d'impôts annoncées sont financés
par le déficit la dette
elle est bonne nouvelle de la
conjoncture sur lesquels vous misez
depuis le début du quinquennat 18,5
milliards d'euros c'est l'augmentation
des recettes d'impôt net perçu par
l'état en 2020
conjuguer un vent de croissance
inespérée à des recettes fiscales
exceptionnellement dynamiques et à la
baisse des taux d'intérêt
quand avez vous fait c'est donc un
budget en 3d déficits dettes dépenses
publiques
la prévision de déficit pour 2020 est
passé à 2,2 pour cent du pib soit une
baisse de 0,1 par rapport à 2019
c'est le plus faible effort en la
matière depuis dix ans notre drette
dette frôle dangereusement avec les 100
% et se situe 20 points au dessus de
celle de l'union européenne
quant aux dépenses publiques elle
augmente en volume de 0 4% certes
mais de 1,6 pour cent en valeur soit
près de 20 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
ce budget n'est qu'une fuite en avant
mais les chiffres sont des réalités que
vous ne pouvez nier les commissions
compétentes du parlement européen après
avoir auditionné pour la deuxième fois
madame goulard commissaires désignés par
le chef de l'état rejeté très
massivement cette candidature par un
score sans appel c'est sans précédent
pour la première fois un tel camouflet
est infligé à la france le chef de
l'état lui-même manifestement sonnés par
l'ampleur de ce rejet s'est laissé aller
à une réaction pour le moins surprenante
un mélange d'émotions fébrile et d'
antiparlementarisme de mauvais aloi il
nous a fait savoir qu'il ne comprenait
pas quel aveu quel aveu
par quel aveuglement par quelle
arrogance par quelle méconnaissance des
institutions européennes à commencer par
celle du parlement européen et c'est une
ancienne députée européenne qui vous le
dit par quelle méconnaissance
le chef de l'état at il pu avoir une
telle réaction à la fois des places et
méprisante et c'est contraire à une
stratégie française crédible et sérieuse
en europe car de tous les groupes
politiques de toutes les nationalités
est devenue la même interrogation
comment accepter qu'une enquête
judiciaire disqualifiant madame gaulard
pour être ministre à paris ne la
disqualifie pas pour être commissaire à
bruxelles monsieur
[Musique]